They definitely have to be open minded.
Um,
as long as you are willing to take yourself out of your body and see things from
someone else's perspective,
that's all I can really ask for in a significant other.
Hmm.
First round again.
Okay.
Hm.
I'm an introvert.
I would enjoy someone that is a little bit more extroverted,
trying to,
not someone that's like,
it goes off the handle and it was just like bouncing everywhere.
Whenever you're ready.
I don't want to date like a gym rat where like every day and that's all they
want to do.
Um,
but I mean,
someone else that has that as like a priority in their life as well.
Just the help motivate me to also like,
Hey,
all right.
I know you're tired,
but like just get off your ass and just being able to quick workout.
Hmm.
All right.
I've actually been a smoker since I was 18.
I have switched off of cigarettes to vaping.
I know it's noxious,
the people that don't understand the why,
but that is something that is a part of my daily life.
Okay.
Right.
Sexual,
I'm not trying to get choked out or you know,
have like a rope around my throat.
Um,
small kinks are fine.
Like I guess I'll draw the line of like no feet just cause I'm not interested in
that and I don't want anyone touching mine.
So
Oh
more open minded.
You are the more willing you are to see where the other person is coming from
and hopefully meet them just because people that are generally closed minded you
can't really have like open discussions with actually like try to get some work
is already set in their ways.
Extremely liberal or on the flip side if you're extremely conservative like even
though I might share more views with you,
once again you'll be more closed minded towards other people that don't share
similar views.
My Dad got married when he was 20 [inaudible] 22 and 26 not even close.
Um,
but I would prefer probably be at least married by 30.
I actually am looking for something more I guess solid.
I'm tired of just like dating people for like Oh hey six months,
four months.
I'm actually looking for like long term at this point.
Hmm.
There are some pretty witty people,
which is fun.
Like regardless of the people that left early or the people that stayed all the
way to the end,
it was a pleasure talking to all of them,
I guess.
That's
nice to meet you guys with John,
so yeah,
we'll see where it goes.
Yeah.